hi Matt well cheer with 3.take Nick
Gillespie we're here for ask a
libertarian 2012 marking the publication
in paperback form of the Declaration of
Independence we are in lightning round
before Nick mode the first question
comes from the great state of Ohio Joe
Reardon asks what's the most libertarian
movie I'm gonna say two things the first
is legends of the fall with Brad Pitt
and Hayden Quinn spoiler alert the
climactic scenes ends with a US
congressman shooting a US revenue agent
during Prohibition era it's fantastic
you know very bizarre and kind of glossy
Hollywood movie that is incredibly
skeptical of government and government
power it opens with the patriarch of the
family Anthony Perkins Hopkins rather
leaving the US Army saying that
governments are only there to kill
people he refuses to participate in the
Indian Wars anymore and then the other
one is the incredibles which came out a
few years ago and was widely and I think
accurately read as a kind of I'm Randy
an homage about why we shouldn't let why
we shouldn't force superior people make
them hide their talent or appear normal
I actually looked at that movie and my
favorite character was the super villain
who I believe was called syndrome he was
born totally genetically normal with no
superpowers but then he developed and
created all of these cool gadgets and
stuff to make himself into a superhero
and it strikes me that's the libertarian
essence of that movie of somebody who
has born one way and transforms himself
through their own imagination and
innovation I would remind you Nick this
is the lightning round yes have you
noticed any libertarian themes in recent
popular culture such as in music movies
video games or TV shows asks Ken
Gillespie yeah it's it's it's all over
the place I mean when you think of like
very popular artists like Lady gaga the
creative destruction built into heard
music borrowing widely and wildly from
all kinds of genres and genders and you
name it and that's across the board and
a lot of popular culture video games
like Grand Theft Auto
and other types of things where you're
engaging with people online in
developing your own narratives I think
that's very libertarian and kind of
impulse in essence shows like Boardwalk
Empire the great HBO series again about
prohibition and how it destroys the
society and makes it horrible my
favorite current TV show is Eagle heart
on Adult Swim with Chris Elliott late of
getalife he plays Chris Monsanto a US
sheriff and it is a more kind of
unnerving depiction of law enforcement
even than when Shaquille O'Neal used to
track along on TV with you know police
force is doing SWAT raids so it's all
over the place you guys read a lot about
pop culture how does that affect
politics asks FX Burkhardt right you
know Matt and I a couple years ago we
did a thing did a piece about how Dallas
helped destroy Ceausescu in Romania
and it's one of the things that's
important a lot of conservatives gripe
all the time that oh you know every
movie is liberal and all the people in
Hollywood are liberal and there's a
conservative blacklist and if we could
only make more movies of that
conservative themes we win that's not
how culture works the real way the
culture works is by giving people a
space and a place to imagine different
lives and to take off-the-rack culture
and and you know tailor it to their
needs this is what happened in church
eskas romania where due to reasons that
are too complicated to go into here they
were allowed among very few Western
products they were allowed to watch
Dallas on TV and they saw in Dallas a
possible future for themselves in which
choo-choo-choo Ches COO had to go and
believe it or not Larry Hagman who's a
big limousine liberal a horrible
horrible character in American politics
became a I con of liberation from a you
know just a horrible government and you
know think of that when you watch the
new Dallas which is premiering sometime
very soon and he's a pitchman for
Romanian oil companies or even Russian
oil companies in Romania we have a
chapter in this book called we're all
mutants now that talks a lot about this
culture and and other chapters
throughout that talk about similar
themes this is ask a libertarian twenty
twelve we're gonna be wrapping up here
pretty soon stay tuned
you